(clapping bangs)
- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is believe in yourself.
Over to you, Snoop Dogg.
(whooshing and bang)
(rooster croaking)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ Every morning
- I just, I just go back to
that time when I was young
and I didn't know what
I wanted to do in life.
And once I finally grabbed a
hold to what I wanted to do,
which was this music thing.
- [Woman] Right.
- And I loved every minute of it,
despite me not being able to
make money or have a career,
I had to believe in myself.
And I want to say that to
the youngsters out there
that's watching, you know.
Believe in anything that you believe in
but have the most belief in it yourself.
Whether it's being a doctor, a lawyer,
or a chemist, or whatever it is.
You have to believe yourself
and then once you believe
the dream will come true.
And then people will believe in you.
That's what dreams are made of.
You have to believe in it
and then the dream can come to life.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'